und es ist aber dann schon historisch
wenn allein Anklage erhoben wird weil es
wäre zum allerersten Mal in der
amerikanischen Geschichte das ein
Präsident im Amt oder in diesem Fall ein
Ex-Präsident tatsächlich
angeklagt wird und wenn das tatsächlich
passieren würde wäre dann eine
Kandidatur 2024 noch denkbar oder völlig
ausgeschlossen rechtlich gesehen
eigentlich kein Problem also er könnte
erstens antreten weiterhin zweitens
könnte er sogar gewählt werden weil nach
amerikanischem Recht selbst wenn er
verurteilt würde könnte er gewählt
werden er dachte nur nicht selber wählen
je nachdem genau je nachdem wie welche
anlagepunkte tatsächlich am Ende zum
Urteil führen also er könnte Präsident
werden obwohl er für diese Taten ich sag
mal salopp verknackt wird